welcome everyone I am Indy Burke on the
Dean of the Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies and we just feel
really lucky to be able to host these
events here I want to thank the
organizing group of the tairy
interdisciplinary lectureships they've
just done a fantastic job by bringing us
Tom Lovejoy who's a great friend of the
school and has been giving some great
presentations earlier culminating today
but my job is not to introduce Tom my
job is to introduce the introducer so
these are complicated lectureships but
we sort of embody interdisciplinarity
tonight I am by training a biogeochemist
and I am introducing dr. Paul Sabin who
is a historian environmental historian
he directs the Yale environmental
humanities initiative here he's also a
great friend of our school he's written
an award-winning book called the bet and
let's welcome Paul Sabin I hope my
introduction lives up to being
introduced it's a high that's a high bar
so I am here I guess representing the
history department and the Yale
environmental humanities initiative
which is a new initiative of the last
couple years and we've been trying to
gather up people from across the campus
who are working on the environment and
the humanities and trying to connect
them and share share their work together
and one of the activities that I think
is characteristic of the environmental
humanities is the effort to try to bring
together the science Sciences with the
humanities and to think about the
broader introduced by a framework for
thinking about environmental problems
and so that's why it's one reasons why
it's a particular pleasure to host to be
part of hosting Tom Lovejoy Lovejoy's
talks and in and because in seeing a
scientist thinking broadly about ethics
and about society and
about how we should be taking into
account and thinking about our future
given the dire dire predictions that are
incredibly are being circulated daily it
seems even just in the last two weeks
both about the about wildlife
populations and the heating of the
oceans and and other things so just
briefly for those of you who haven't
been at the previous lectures ought to
introduce dr. Lovejoy for the past
thirty years he's been working on the
intersection between climate change and
biodiversity he received his Bachelor
bachelor science and also his doctorate
in biology from here at Yale and
starting in the 70s he was leading in
bringing attention to the issue of
tropical deforestation particularly in
the Amazon so I I remember growing up in
the 80s hearing about deforestation in
the Amazon and I think I was benefiting
from from his work at that time he's
been working in the Amazon since 1965
in the in 1980 he was involved with the
global 2000 report to the President
projecting global extinctions some of
the similar research that just was
coming out this week I think it was from
World Wildlife Fund right and at that
time was involved in coining the term
for biological diversity he's got two co
edited books that were published in 1992
in 2005 that helped that that credit him
with helping to found the the field of
climate change biology and one of the
things I think is distinctive about dr.
Lovejoy is that he is is the way that he
has married science with with
conservation and in practice and form of
global activism I would say in toward
towards conservation and one of the ways
in which he's done that is is involved
in developing the debt for nature swap
programs to try to find ways to generate
funds to protect nature natural
ecosystems and his work in lis in
leaving the minimum critical size of
ecosystems project and he's been
recognized widely for his work in 2001
he received the prestigious Tyler prize
for environmental achievement in 2009 he
was
winner of the BBVA foundation frontiers
of knowledge award for ecology and
conservation biology and also has been
appointed the conservation fellow by a
National Geographic and more recently
has returned to academia where he's been
teaching and and doing research
George Mason as a university professor
which he in the department of
environmental science and policy and he
took that role on in starting in 2010 so
as I mentioned I guess III actually just
met Tom Lovejoy for the first time just
a few minutes ago but I feel like I've
been hearing about him since when I was
not as an undergraduate here at Yale in
the 1980s into the early 1990s and so I
feel that I know him as a champion of
the environment as a end of conservation
and as part of really a Yale tradition
of environmental leaders and and a
steward of the environmental programs
here at Yale and someone who I know and
as being a broad-minded person not just
narrowly focused on biology but
concerned with the humanities and public
affairs as well I think in that sense a
model environmental leader to come out
of the Yale programs delighted to
welcome you again for your third tarry
lecture and invite you to come up and
there'll be time for questions
afterwards
[Applause]
okay good
so last week we began by sort of
exploring value systems religious
perspectives about life on Earth and how
humanity might fit with all of that and
in essence how to embed human aspiration
in nature
Tuesday we looked at our widespread
practice of fragmenting nature leaving
fragments all over the place losing
species and then began to look about
ways you could start stitching these
fragments back together again what I
want to do in the final lecture is look
at this issue of biodiversity and
climate change and let's start by
looking at biodiversity and climate
change this is a peregrine falcon on
Central Park West looking down at the
climate March before the UN General
Assembly about three years ago and on
the 9th of January the 3rd book on
biodiversity and climate change will
publish thanks again to Yale University
Press
and it's it's really very interesting to
compare the three books in the first
appearing in 1992 all you could really
do is look at what had happened in the
geologic past and try imagine how some
of that might apply to the future by the
time of the second you could see the
fingerprints of climate change all over
the place and by the time this one is at
has become very obvious that
biologically we need to
limit climate change to no more than one
and a half degrees and that's one of the
messages I hope to convey this afternoon
so I'm not going to get into the
physical changes ice to non ice sea
level rise I'm going to pretty quickly
after introducing this amazing Swedish
scientist get into the biology of all of
this what's happening to it and then
ultimately how biology actually gives us
an important way to create a much more
hopeful future than the current
trajectory would lead us to so I always
like to get into this topic by not
pretending to be an expert on climate
change I'm not an expert on climate
change I'm an expert if there is such a
thing on how climate change and the
biodiversity of the planet interact but
I find it useful to start with Irenaeus
by explaining that when he wrote a very
famous paper in 1896 that he was really
trying to answer the question why is the
planet a habitable temperature for
humans and other forms of life why isn't
it too cold and the answer of course was
the natural level of greenhouse gases in
the atmosphere
most notably carbon dioxide and he
actually calculated with pencil and
paper what doubling pre-industrial
levels of co2 would do to the average
temperature of the earth and it came at
precisely where the fancy supercomputer
models provided today not the detail of
course and in addition he would not have
been particularly aware of the actual
climatic history of the earth in the
preceding tens and hundreds of thousands
of years as we can see here
nor that last 10,000 years on the upper
right a period of unusual stability in
the climatic system which includes all
recorded human history a significant
amount of unrecorded human history the
origins of Agriculture the origin of
human settlements and basically you have
to conclude that the entire human
enterprise is actually based on the
assumption of a stable climate and that
of course we're changing and I won't
take you through a lot of details of
that I'm going to go straight to the
kinds of changes that are being observed
in nature so many parts of the world in
this particular case the Royal Botanic
Gardens at Kew various species of plants
are flowering earlier every year where
there are long data sets like it the
famous Leopold Shack can continued after
his death by his daughter Nina you can
see the same pattern of earlier flying
taunt of flowering times and it's not
just plants that are responding it's
also animals so tree swallows are
migrating earlier nesting earlier laying
eggs earlier even a couple birds have
ceased to migrate and we are seeing
organisms change where they actually
occur geographically so this is one of
the two best known species of
butterflies in North America called the
Edith's Checkerspot and very distinctly
you can see it has been moving northward
and upward and altitude in response to
to changing climate basically tracking
its required conditions also in
California the Joshua Tree is now
growing outside of Joshua Tree National
Park because of climate change and these
kinds of changes occurring not only on
the land there
in the water occurring in the oceans and
if anything those changes seem to be
happening faster in ocean organisms may
because so many of them actually are not
rooted in any sense and their medium is
fluid so in the Chesapeake Bay the Great
estuary on the east eastern coast of
South America one of the really
important communities from an economic
point of view but also a biodiversity
point of view is the eelgrass community
and they turn out to be very sensitive
to water temperature so as it has been
warming the southern boundary of the
eelgrass community has been marching
north year after year and the changes
we're seeing are not just in the
temperate zone or the boreal zone we're
also seeing changes in the tropics there
may be often less often about
temperature than about changes in
moisture patterns here we're looking at
the legendary cloud forests of
Monteverde Costa Rica an ecosystem that
depends essentially 98% on condensation
from clouds is the source source of its
moisture and what has been happening
there is clouds have been forming less
frequently at the altitude of Monteverdi
and forming higher creating more dry
days every year not something very good
for a cloud dependent ecosystem and we
have a plethora of examples or what are
what are called decoupling events when
two features in nature which are tightly
linked and timing turn out to use
different mechanisms for that timing one
using day length and the other using
temperature and so they decouple and in
this particular instance the snow that
would normally provide cover for
snowshoe hares in their white winter
pail äj--
is no longer there as long into the
spring and that's a very tough thing for
snowshoe hares because their ability to
change the timing of of their change and
in fur from from winter College to
summer college is very inelastic it is
in fact very day length dependent and so
you get lots of instances of bright
snowshoe hare rabbits basically sitting
ducks on non white backgrounds so this
particular slide I always point out I
would penalize any student for because
it's utterly unreadable but it's to make
the point that what I've been telling
you is not a collection of isolated
anecdotes it's now statistically robust
that nature is responding to climate
change almost anywhere in the world you
look so those are basic basically minor
ripples in the fabric of life the really
the real issue is what does it look like
looking ahead and one of the things one
can do to get a sense of what might take
place is to look at the climatic
conditions at a particular community
particularly in this case a sugar maple
normally lives within and then you can
project where that climatic envelope
will occur at say double pre-industrial
levels of co2 and the bad news on this
is that anything that you love sugar
maples for from autumn foliage to maple
sugar at double pre-industrial levels
you're going to have to go to Canada and
all the great complex computer models
come out with that conclusion
this image is here to make the point
that the two physical parameter is most
important for terrestrial organisms or
temperature and moisture and for aquatic
ones temperature and acidity or pH and
all of those are changing freshwater
species like like trout which are very
dependent on cold water are particularly
vulnerable and so are species that live
in high places like this charming rabbit
relative called the pika which lives in
isolated colonies in the Rocky Mountains
and what happens with these kinds of
species is they move upward and altitude
tracking their required conditions until
there is no further up to go and at
least one of these colonies has already
winked at any species that basically
lives near the coast is gonna have to
cope with sea-level rise some will do
better than others yesterday I have the
treat to go to Hammond asset where I
hadn't been since freshman year and one
of the characteristics Birds there is
this salt marsh Sparrow which has a
really specialized biology and it
basically has to complete its nesting
cycle between two spring tides get it
all done sufficiently in two and a half
weeks that the young can survive some
experience with salt water and the salt
marsh Sparrow has salt more Sparrow
habitat is not advancing as quickly as
the sea level rise so they're getting a
serious squeeze another interesting
thing to do is think about what sea
level rise means for the Everglades you
know the famous river of grass and
basically all of that is seriously
vulnerable already to
water intrusion it will respond in
various ways but certain organisms like
the American alligator are going to be
suddenly at a disadvantage compared to
the American crocodile because there's
going to be more salt in their habitat
and the crocodile is actually
physiologically capable of excreting
salt so I think we can look forward to a
Florida with more crocodiles and fewer
alligators any organism on islands
especially low-lying islands like the
Florida Keys is basically in deep
trouble the key deer simply won't
survive unless they're transplanted
somewhere else and even species on
islands that aren't low will have
serious problems because the climatic
conditions on the island will actually
change and there's no way that the
organisms that live there really can
follow them and of course there are a
whole suite of organisms that basically
have a natural history that related to
ice and the polar bear of course is the
poster child for that so those are sort
of the broad-brush ways of looking at it
going ahead but there are serious
complications and the first of these
which we examined last week our
propensity in sort of its sucio of
fashion to fragment natural habitats
basically makes it tremendously
difficult for the organisms in those
habitats to be able to move and track
their required climatic conditions
basically we've created an obstacle
course and that actually is one of the
easiest complications to do something
about
because as we explored last week there
are lots of good reasons to put natural
connections back into the landscape and
when you do that it's much easier for
the organisms to track the conditions
they require the second complication is
a much tougher one and it's involved in
the conclusion that I will get to in a
little bit that we really do need to
stop climate change at one and a half
degrees and that is simply we know that
in the past that entire biological
communities don't move as a unit it's
the individual organisms and species
that move and so basically it becomes
something that's very hard to manage and
here's here's what happened after the
last glacier retreated in Europe and
we're looking if I remember correctly at
three mammal species to tree species and
insect species there is no common
pattern of their response to the change
in climate so that's that's something
that's really hard to do anything about
and why it's really important to try and
limit the amount of climate change so
that we don't actually have to cope with
natural habitats that are coming apart
and very fluid and unpredictable ways
third reason to worry about more climate
change greater climate change is we know
even though our computer models are
linear and gradual that the environment
doesn't actually work that way we know
for example that the climate system has
abrupt changes built into it in the past
one of them involving this incredible
current called the global conveyor belt
which moves warmth around the globe
coming from the Pacific and the Indian
Ocean and up the Atlantic until finally
it cools between Greenland and Europe
and sinks down and that's why Europe
basically has a habitable climate and
it's been known to shut down in geologic
time and the probable mechanism for that
is actually copious amounts of fresh
water from melting glacial ice sort of
cutting off that actual sinking action
but even before something like that
nobody can give you any prediction when
something like that might happen we are
seeing abrupt changes in ecosystems and
one of the most dramatic is here in
North America it involves the coniferous
forests of Western North America and
basically what's happening there
is that the warming climate has tipped
the balance in favor of the native bark
beetles so in this video of British
Columbia at the beginning you just may
be able to detect a little red pinpricks
of beetle outbreaks but as time goes on
and the winters are warmer and more
beetles survive the winter and they get
in another generation suddenly this tips
the balance in favor of the beetles and
even when we get shortly here to 1985
when there was a cold winter and they
were beaten back they weren't beaten
back that much and the consequence is
that their large areas of the Western
North America from southern Alaska down
to southern Colorado where there is
massive coniferous tree mortality and
nobody I think really can't
what's gonna happen to those forests
it's sort of unprecedented a similar
kind of abrupt change is already
occurring in tropical coral reefs which
all look like this when I was an
undergraduate and a graduate student
these incredible Technicolor highly
diverse highly productive communities
enormous ly important to the 5% of
humanity that live within a hundred
metres of coral reefs and it turns out
the very partnership on which the
tropical coral reef is built the
relationship between the coral animal
and the alga is very sensitive in
particular to temperature change
not very long and not that much warmer
and the coral animal ejects the alga and
the entire ecosystem collapses and
basically goes from Technicolor to black
and white and everything that a tropical
coral reef was about in a healthy state
basically collapses that was first
noticed in 1983 last year more than half
of the Great Barrier Reef of Australia
had a bleaching event and looking ahead
into their coming summer and the weather
predictions projections we could well
see the entire Great Barrier Reef have a
bleaching event and they can come back
from those events but not repeatedly
more recently we had an example on the
front page of the New York Times about
the great kelp forests in the Pacific
off the western coast of North America
and it's another one of these
idiosyncratic relationships in this case
there is a native perch in the purple
urgent and warming waters
have allowed its numbers to explode to
the point that basically they've eaten
down those forests to the point that
they're you know basically not kelp
forests anymore so I think what we're
finding is you can do elegant climatic
models you can do elegant vegetation
models but the way the systems are going
to react in the end will come down to
idiosyncratic relationships between
particular species within them and then
lastly there's there's some changes
going on that are at an even bigger
scale I call them system change and one
of them involves my favorite place in
the world the Amazon and here you see
how moisture is generated hour by hour
and it's mostly over the equator and
mostly over the oceans with a major
exception being when that moisture
enters the Amazon basin and it recycles
five or six times as it goes from the
Atlantic to the Andes and this will show
a model that makes it a little more
obvious because you're not looking at
anything other than South America
but the interesting thing is yes the
Amazon makes half of its own rainfall
but it also provides important moisture
outside the Amazon and particular to the
agricultural belt of Brazil south of the
Amazon basin more recently we've been
seeing unprecedented droughts 2005 2010
again in 2016 I think it's because there
is a combined synergistic effect between
deforestation widespread use of fire and
actual climate change and South
America's leading climate scientist
Carlos no beret and I
I've concluded that there is a tipping
point close at hand that these are
probably the first flickers indicating
that and that if we have any brains
we'll find a way to do some
reforestation and the Amazon and build
back a margin of safety and of course
there's a huge amount of biodiversity
tied up and all that a huge amount of
carbon that could could end up in the
atmosphere and make climate change even
worse and so Mary Evelyn thought it
would be really important for me to give
you a little taste of what this is like
actually when you're on the ground so
and I'm going to need your help again
this is a three-minute video that a
student produced in a storytelling group
great thanks
I don't have the biology or a planet so
that's their only the fastness of years
from now let's not think about nature
this some little hatchet protected area
in your human dominated system let's
start thinking about human aspiration
[Music]
so we're at cam 41 which is my honor the
best of the research cast we have here
in the heart of the Amazon and that's
because it's virtually unbroken forest
from the earth all the way
[Music]
bhakta diversity is my everything and I
will get the whole picture
it's incontrovertibly but to a priority
and typing large areas and connecting
smaller is when I would just this summit
up within a single example from this
project 100x it is a forest if it's a
crime at the loses half of the species
of the birds of the forest and in less
than 15 years so you may have applause
but it doesn't have a holistic review so
what this means you actually need to
manage it as a system so that it can
generate the rainfall that's essential
Moisture is returning to luminaire masks
through evaporation of complex surfaces
of the parts through the action or
transpiration of people is process
completes itself five or six times the
find the history to the high wall of the
Indian theatre mass moves up and most of
that moisture blocks out and medicine a
terrain and creates especially the 20%
of the world's rivers in the Amazon
system
[Music]
[Music]
we are how can we get back in so the
amazing thing about that video was I
didn't have a script that student took
various things I said and stitch them
together and made the script that's
great so so now sort of beginning to
head towards what can we do about all of
this because there's no point in waving
your hands about a problem without a
solution we have to look at all the
elements of change that are going on and
the other big system change is the
acidification of the oceans not
recognized until 2005 we all sort of
ignored basic high school chemistry that
some of that excess co2 in the
atmosphere would become carbonic acid
why worry about that because there are
hundreds of thousands of species that
build shells or skeletons of calcium
carbonate and that is pH dependent some
of them we know of that others are less
familiar and see if we can get this to
actually move oh maybe not so that that
is a tiny little organism it's a tiny
little snail that exists and untold
numbers in the North Atlantic off of
Alaska and it's basically the base of
the food chain and it is very vulnerable
to ocean acidification first indication
that there was an issue was when
somebody collected some and kept them
overnight and
a small container of seawater on a ship
on a ship and the next morning their
shells were etched from the
acidification from their own co2 being
exhaled into the water so the point here
is that basically we're dealing with at
this point aspects of how the earth
systems works that we really don't
understand it just makes very little
sense to keep proceeding in the
direction we're going and find out how
some of those things might or might not
work so what can we do about all of this
first of all we need to think about
where we stop and some of these images
date from when everybody is thinking two
degrees is where we should stop actually
at two degrees you would have a whole
series of consequences around ice but a
whole series around ecosystems and if
you want one soundbite why two degrees
is too much it's that the last time the
planet was two degrees warmer the oceans
were four to six meters higher it would
not be good for New Haven among other
places
so for a long time those of us who sort
of been looking at the biology of the
planet had serious reservations about
two degrees at the Paris climate meeting
when finally the possibility of less
began to reappear interestingly enough
because island nations were speaking up
and suddenly people were thinking well
one one did anybody say it was an okay
thing to let an entire nation state
disappear under the waves I mean it is
like it had been totally ignored when at
the same time all the big country
coastlines were going to be vulnerable
to the same sea-level rise so we've
heard recently from the
Intergovernmental Panel about one and a
half degree
the particular point that Lee Hanna and
I make in the new book is that you have
to keep it lower than one and a half
degrees if you want to have a
biologically manageable planet because
it'll all start coming apart in ways
that it's very hard to predict so what
are some of the things you can do about
this let's go back for a minute so I
like to call this guy dr. planet and
he's made the diagnosis now he's trying
to figure out what to prescribe and
there's some obvious conservation
strategies you might get into and then
you have to worry a lot about the co2 in
the atmosphere so revising conservation
strategies they're obvious things
putting natural connections back into
the landscape the kind of thing we
talked about last week
minimizing other stresses on these
ecosystems obviously helps avoid
synergies you can think at least in the
in the shorter term about building up
natural systems to the way they used to
function here South Florida that would
resist a certain amount of storm surge
there obviously is a gigantic energy
agenda and we're not changing rapidly
enough on the energy base of society at
all I mean that's I think it's terribly
obvious but one part of this long
ignored is how the biology of the planet
has been playing into this whole climate
change picture and you sort of hear sort
of tangentially mentioned the role of
forests and all of this the actual
annual emissions of forests is quite
significant and depending whether you
look at the gross amount of mitad or the
net amount admitted it's between 10 and
30 percent of annual emissions so the
question is is there something that we
could do to play with this annual
equation
the emissions from forest destruction
about five times as much from basically
old ecosystem which systems which is
what fossil fuels are and half going in
the atmosphere and the other half
essentially dividing between land and
the oceans might we even be able to turn
one of those arrows in the other
direction and it's important to do
because greenhouse gases stay in the
atmosphere for a very long time
so one of the really important questions
if biology can help us with is are there
ways that we can use natural systems to
lower the amount of co2 in the
atmosphere and therefore the amount of
climate change so essentially there are
two things you can do you can restore
natural ecosystems with lots of side
benefits it won't be enough so we need
to think really hard and developing ways
we can do it not biologically but
interestingly if you look at the history
of the planet there were two times when
there were literally screamingly high
levels of co2 in the atmosphere and on
both occasions natural processes brought
it down to pre-industrial levels pretty
impressive what the planet can do but
that takes tens of millions of years and
we don't have that luxury so as of
January we got new numbers about the
amount of co2 in the atmosphere from
destructive destruction of ecosystems it
was larger than anybody had realized
before essentially equal to what remains
in living ecosystems and that means
restoring ecosystems can literally take
tens of parts per million out of the
Atmos
here give you a framework the
pre-industrial level was 280 parts per
million
we'd like to stop at 350 but that's you
know rear view mirror because we're
already at 401 but if you took 30 parts
per million out of the atmosphere
suddenly you'd be at 370 so these are
substantial numbers and I'm really
delighted to have tonight to show to you
pre-publication some maps about the
carbon potential of ecosystem
restoration produced at the Woods Hole
Research Centre and Zandar news caecus
right there worked very hard in that
program and you can see actually that
it's it's it's a very impressive
possibility so what about soil carbon
this gives you a sense of how much
carbon has been removed by agriculture
and other human activities it is a
substantial number and the flip side of
it is you restore carbon to the soil you
get more fertile soil better ecosystems
better agriculture so this shows current
carbon storage get this right here and
the scale is in millions of grams of
carbon per hectare so it adds up quickly
is the point so this is the current
carbon storage above-ground this is
potential carbon storage
and that's how much has been unrealized
so there's a lot that can be done based
on that kind of map so we're not going
to reforest Manhattan or London or parts
of Rio de Janeiro but there are lots of
parts of the world where we could
actually benefit in additional ways than
just carbon reduction by doing this
ecosystem restoration so and so one big
piece of it is how we manage forests and
it doesn't mean you can't get some
economic productivity out of forests but
it's important to keep an eye on the
carbon balance and there are all these
degraded grasslands around the world
what do you get when you restore
degraded grasslands and grasslands and
grazing lands you actually get better
grazing that could be cattle or it could
be native species and then and then we
really have to modify agriculture and
stop it from leaking carbon and start
managing it in ways that restores Carbon
builds up carbon and increases soil
fertility so there's so many reasons to
be doing these kinds of things anyway
that there's sort of this double
incentive it's good in terms of
ecosystem benefits it's also very good
in terms of climate benefits and more
recently attention has been focused on
what's called blue carbon things along
coastlines my main illustration here are
mangroves which turned out to be very
mangrove dense that's the natural
distribution of mangroves around the
world here's some statistics about them
so basically it would make sense to
leave
standing from a carbon point of view
well there are other reasons to do it
too and Kevon sook dev did this analysis
some years ago actually question was was
the economics of clearing mangroves for
shrimp farms and if you just look at it
on the surface in a superficial way of
course you can clear the mangroves to do
the shrimp farms if you then look at the
actual numbers without the subsidies in
this particular case it's a much less
compelling case and then if you look at
it in terms of the ecosystem services
actually without the carbon benefit you
would never do it at all so if you add a
third or fourth analysis there which I
don't have
it becomes an overwhelming case to do
the shrimp farming other places there's
no reason they actually have to be in
mangrove coastal regions and then woven
into this is the whole food and land use
trajectory as human population soars and
there have been really good scholars
who've looked at all of this and
determined that you can actually feed
all the coming billions of people an
adequate diet without destroying another
square inch of nature and that involves
improving agricultural practices in
places where productivity is low it
includes eliminating food waste there's
like thirty to forty percent of all food
is wasted World Wildlife Fund u.s. now
has a food waste program even you know a
buffet practice in a hotel or a cruise
ship has to change the psychology of the
passengers so they don't have lots of
food left
because passengers seem to like to come
to the buffet even if they're at the
very end and just see a whole array of
choices and they're working on ways to
do that and so this sort of gives that
whole picture what ecosystem restoration
can do and I think the the wonderful
thing about it is that it allows us to
restore the functionality of this planet
in a way that's a benefit to human
beings and other forms of life as
Irenaeus would have said making it
habitable for other other humans and
other forms of life thank you very much
[Applause]
now they want their recording could you
give us your thoughts on what is going
on in Brazil and we talked about
population I understand the new leader
has his regard toward women it sounds
like he just sees them as vessels for
reproduction and I'm wondering how you
feel about you know what I hope you see
for Brazil so I'm not surprised I got
that question I've spent at least half
of the last three days trying to get a
better trajectory there so basically the
new president of Brazil came in because
the people were fed up with crime in the
streets fred up with corruption and fed
up with a miserable economy that the
Workers Party had gotten everything into
but then there's all this other language
and baggage and we'll just we'll see how
it plays out but not in a way of just
sitting on our hands so you know he he
has proposed merging the agriculture
ministry with the Environment Ministry
and all the living ministers of the
environment signed a letter encouraging
him to think differently to put it
politely and he agreed that he wouldn't
do that and then on Tuesday his sensual
essentially future chief of staff said
oh we're gonna do it anyway right well
then yesterday they said well this is
not a done deal
and then interestingly the
agriculturalists decided they didn't
like this idea rather than sort of
seeing it as an opportunity where they
might run roughshod over the environment
interests they thought I will never get
anywhere
so we'll just have to see you know it'll
be a day by day and who talks to who at
particular places and you know it's just
life you have to deal with it and and
just reminder that after the talk we'll
be having a reception just at the end of
the hall so I hope you'll stay and join
us
yeah and it's tasty biodiversity I can
tell you hey do you feel like adding a
co2 emissions tax would be a good way to
force the world into reducing emissions
yeah I mean there's there's no question
that a tax on carbon is the simplest and
most efficient way to to make a really
serious dent and they're really
interesting questions about what you
could do with that revenue including the
simplistic one of simply giving it back
you know to the American public as a
rebate of some sort and so that idea
essentially I believe was first proposed
by my classmate Bill Nordhaus and that's
at least a large part of the reason he
recently was awarded the Nobel Prize
it's um I've heard you talk a lot over a
number of years about the need to manage
the Amazon as a system that's one unit
but there are nine countries that
control and manage the Amazon oftentimes
with their own agenda and you know with
increasing nationalism in the region
what it what is your perspective for you
know moving towards that goal well it's
a really good question very good
question so I mean you saw the
hydrological cycle of the Amazon
it basically means if you want to
maintain the Amazon and also the
moisture it feeds south of Brazil you
have to manage it as a system because
that's how it works and there are nine
countries and one of them is in a real
mess at the moment Venezuela but there
is an Amazon cooperation treaty which
has had little flickers of effectiveness
in the past particularly when Fernando
Henrique Cardoso was president of Brazil
and we had a good dinner and he got it
right so it's not simple but I think
there is growing recognition in a lot of
these countries that they actually have
to find ways to collaborate and on the
20th of November that Brazilian
ambassador is having a lunch with the
ambassador of Ecuador the ambassador of
Peru and since the ambassador of
Colombia is away the deputy chief of
mission and yours truly and the
inter-american Development Bank also
understands the need to try and move
this kind of direction so at the same
time you getting these deeply
distracting headlines about the new
government in Brazil you have a main
stream of people who recognize the need
to do something and interestingly if you
pull Brazilians 70 percent will say you
have to protect the Amazon because they
get it Lovejoy
my name is Marc I have a question about
carbon pricing I read an op-ed in LA
Times about two or three days ago
basically saying that dr. your house
scheme actually is slowing down
globally slowing down the effort to try
to reduce global warming because the
price maybe miss price do you have any
opinion as to what should be a so you
know is it the details of what the price
should be are always going to be a
matter for debate but the idea is
fundamentally sound
it's always inspiring to hear you talk
so I just wanted to say that but well so
can you give us your take on the
geoengineering proposals to try to
reduce solar radiation in this way
mitigate well that's one of my one of my
favorite subjects and it's also in the
book so geoengineering proposals are
proposals to do things at the planetary
scale to deal with not climate change
but the effects of climate change so an
example would be to mimic what volcanoes
do naturally occasionally and in a
spotty way and put a lot of sulfur up in
the atmosphere and reduce the amount of
radiation coming in well first of all
that does nothing for acidification of
the oceans just a temperature thing
second of all the minute you do
something like that and there may be
downsides to it and whatever is global
in scale the downside will be global in
scale too and thirdly for that kind of a
thing the minute you stop doing it for
whatever reason you go right back to the
temperature you would have been at if
nothing had ever been done so I think we
need to be really thoughtful about
geoengineering because you really have
to include the oceans and how you think
about all of this and I think basically
the best solution is to let's get back
to the point where you have a planet
that functions in the in the kind of way
that projects protects that stable
climate
um with the reports that came out this
week about the 60 percent decline in in
wildlife species around the world I was
hearing some some talk on different
radio programs about the need for a
level similar to the climate change
conventions on protecting wildlife and
not furthering species loss I guess with
the upcoming UN conference in in Egypt I
believe on biodiversity do you have any
hopes for what might come out of that if
any so the so just for those who don't
know all the pieces there's there are
three Environment conventions that came
out of the Earth Summit in Rio one is
about the climate and you've read about
that to a fare-thee-well
and if I would proceed it criticized it
over time it was that it was too
dominated by physical scientists and
biological scientists have only recently
been able to get some purchase and that
had a lot to do with the recent one and
a half degree report they put out
biodiversity convention has sort of been
in the shadows and it could have been
more effective in the way it conducted
its business I don't want to spend time
looking back at that in 2020 it will
have a conference of the parties in
Beijing and it will set the targets for
the subsequent decade not having meat
met the targets in the decade that we'll
be closing at that point and a lot of us
are worried that the targets will be too
timid because of that fear of failure
when it really in many ways will be the
last decade of opportunity to really
make major gains and I that's why I went
to Beijing about four weeks ago
and so there's some serious discussion
going over there and I got appointed on
the International Advisory Committee for
the Chinese we'll see what that turns
into but that's really important and it
will be meeting as a conference
literally two weeks from now in Egypt I
can't go for that because the books
being released in New York but but
there's a lot of serious discussion
going on trying to come up with a dual
wall but ambitious outcome so what I
invite you all to join us at the
reception of all I wanna say thank you
thanks to the Terry lectures for being
Tom
[Music]